.
(Französisch)
Wie heisst das Parlament
und wie setzt es sich zusammen?
Die Bundesversammlung.
Welches ist der höchste Berg
der Schweiz?
Der höchste Berg der Schweiz,
das ist der ...
Die Dufourspitze mit 3'000 ...
Ah, Moment, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe etwas verwechselt.
4'210 m.
Das stimmt nicht ganz.
- Das stimmt nicht?
Es sind 4'234 m.
Stimmt, ich habe alles verwechselt.
Zwei Fehler habe ich gemacht.
Wir haben diesen Schritt nie gewagt.
Zuerst war es die Sprache,
und dann waren die Kinder wichtiger.
Dann die Arbeit, noch mehr Arbeit.
So ist die Zeit vergangen.
Wir sind bald da.
- Oui.
Ganz ruhig, tief durchatmen.
Das Schweizer Einbürgerungsverfahren
ist das strengste in ganz Europa.
Zwar gibt es
nur einen Schweizer Pass,
aber über 2'000 Wege,
ihn zu bekommen.
Das entspricht der Anzahl Gemeinden
in unserem Land.
Zum ersten Mal haben kommunale Behör-
den in allen vier Sprachregionen
Zutritt zu ihren sehr vertraulichen
Anhörungen gewährt.
Beim entscheidenden Schritt
vor der Kommission
müssen die Bewerber/-innen ihre
Swissness unter Beweis zu stellen
und zeigen, dass sie das Räderwerk,
das unser Land antreibt,
bis ins kleinste Detail kennen.
Willkommen
in der Einbürgerungsfabrik,
willkommen bei Fabrique des Suisses,
Far Svizzers,
La Fabrica degli Svizzeri -
"Schweizer machen".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Sind wir hier richtig?
Viele Leute stresst
die Einbürgerungsanhörung derart,
dass sie fast zusammenbrechen.
Ça va?
- Oui.
Ganz, ganz ruhig.
Es wird schon gut gehen.
Wechseln wir ab?
- Gerne.
Wir machen kurz die Einführung.
Wir versuchen, die Zeit einzuhalten.
- 20 Min.
Ja. Wir fangen schon
mit etwas Verspätung an.
Bonjour Madame.
In Lausanne müssen bis Ende 2020
auf Hochtouren
über 1'600 Bewerbungsdossiers
abgearbeitet werden.
Diese wurden noch unter
dem alten Gesetz eingereicht,
so auch das der Benedettos.
Scheitern die beiden Italiener,
fangen sie bei null an.
Einer von fünf Bewerbenden
wird hier im Durchschnitt abgewiesen.
- Ich beginne bei Ihnen,
Frau Benedetto.
Warum wollen Sie Schweizerin werden?
- Unsere ganze Familie lebt hier.
Ausserdem bin ich
seit fast 50 Jahren in der Schweiz.
Ich kümmerte mich um meine Kinder,
arbeitete und schob die Einbürgerung
immer wieder auf.
Ich wollte den Schritt gehen,
aber hoffte,
dass es von alleine passiert.
Okay. Und Sie, Herr Benedetto?
In all den Jahren
haben wir uns gut integriert
in die französische Sprache
und die Bräuche.
Madame, bitte nennen Sie
die fünf grössten Schweizer Städte.
Il y a Zurich, Bâle,
Genève, Lausanne,
Berne.
Perfekt.
Dann, Monsieur, zwei Flüsse?
Zwei Flüsse?
Der Rhein und die Rhone.
Die Rhone entspringt im Wallis,
fliesst durch den Genfersee,
verlässt die Schweiz in Genf
und mündet ins Mittelmeer.
Der Rhein
entspringt im Kanton Graubünden,
fliesst durch den Bodensee,
verlässt die Schweiz in Schaffhausen
und mündet in die Nordsee.
Es gibt Schweizer, die das
nicht so genau wissen - Gratulation.
Machen wir mit Geschichte weiter.
Geografie, Politik, Geschichte.
Egal, was Sie
je über die Schweiz wissen wollten -
das Ehepaar Benedetto
weiss auf alles eine Antwort.
Welche Daten sind wichtig
in der Schweizer Geschichte?
Der Geburtstag der Schweiz 1291.
Also der Bundesbrief zwischen den
Kantonen Uri, Schwyz und Unterwalden
auf dem Rütli.
Sehr gut. Noch ein anderes Datum?
Der Wiener Kongress von 1815.
Dort wurde die Neutralität
der Schweiz erklärt
und die Grenzen
wurden so festgelegt,
wie sie heute sind.
Madame, nennen Sie einige wichtige
Daten der Waadtländer Geschichte.
nahmen die Berner das Waadtland ein
und brachten den Protestantismus.
Dann gibt es noch ein anderes Datum:
1803 ist das Waadtland
der Eidgenossenschaft beigetreten.
Das stimmt.
Als Gemeinderätin ist dieser Auftrag
hier sehr sinnvoll für mich.
Damit würdige ich das Engagement,
das diese Menschen aus dem Ausland
für die Schweiz bringen.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Und 2003?
2003 wurde die kantonale Verfassung
revidiert.
Viele Ausländer/-innen lassen sich
wie die pensionierten Benedettos
erst im fortgeschrittenen Alter
einbürgern.
Die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
war lange verboten,
eine Einbürgerung teuer, da sich die
Kosten nach dem Einkommen richteten
und sich auf mehrere Tausend Franken
belaufen konnten.
Seit 2006 dürfen die Behörden nur
noch die Verfahrenskosten berechnen.
Dennoch gibt es grosse Unterschiede:
In Lausanne
wird man für 800 Fr. eingebürgert.
Fast viermal weniger
als in Freienbach.
Dort muss Andreas 2'900 Fr. bezahlen.
Aber da es braucht mehr,
um den Bewerber
aus der ehemaligen DDR zu entmutigen.
Heute gebe ich die Unterlagen ab.
Die von der Schule
und die ganzen Unterlagen,
die für die Einbürgerung
verlangt waren.
Ziemlich viel.
Andreas hat den kantonalen
Einbürgerungstest bestanden.
Sein Verfahren läuft weiter.
Er wird von der Gemeindeschreiberin
vorgeladen.
Grüezi wohl, Andreas.
Wir haben telefoniert. Die
Unterlagen haben Sie dabei?- Ja.
In unserem Land, wo die Einheimischen
beim Thema Geld lieber schweigen,
müssen sich die Einbürgerungswilligen
bis auf die Unterhosen ausziehen.
Darf ich das herausnehmen? Wir legen
es danach in eine unserer Mappen.
Da kommt noch die Bundessteuer
hinzu.
Gesellschaftstest. Gut absolviert.
Die Geburtsurkunde ...
... hätten Sie
noch nicht einreichen müssen.
Das Zivilstandsamt wird zu einem
späteren Zeitpunkt auf Sie zukommen.
Die Geburtsurkunde darf nicht
älter als sechs Monate sein.
Aha, okay. Gut, dann muss ich
nochmals eine neue beantragen.
Die Steuerrechnung brauche ich
nicht, die gebe ich Ihnen zurück.
Ich bräuchte nur die definitive
Steuerveranlagungsverfügung.
Das sieht so aus: Das ist
diese Doppelseite vom Kanton.
'14 und '15 muss ich noch ...
Die Steuerveranlagungsverfügungen
von '14 und '15
und das Blatt
des kantonalen Steueramts.
Ich hoffe, dass ich die finde.
Andreas dachte, sein Verfahren
würde endlich vorankommen.
Doch der bürokratische Weg
ist kafkaesk.
Bis er
die fehlenden Dokumente erhält,
sind andere evtl.
bereits wieder abgelaufen.
Ich bin in einem Sportverein,
Pistolenschiessen,
aber in Altendorf-Lachen.
Sie müssen sicher nicht zwingend
in einem Freienbacher Verein sein,
nur wegen der Integration - Haupt-
sache, Sie sind in einem Verein.
Das habe ich im Lebenslauf nicht
gesehen. Stehen die Hobbys darauf?
Ich habe noch mehr Hobbys. Angeln.
Aber ich habe es hier
nicht ausgeübt.
Gut.
Wir machen
noch die Behördenanfragen -
beim Amt für Migration
und bei der Polizei.
Dann git es auch noch
eine Arbeitgeberanfrage.
Ja.
Sie werden von uns
immer schön dokumentiert.
Okay, vielen Dank.
- Ich danke Ihnen vielmals.
Seit acht Monaten
wartet Dawit auf diesen Brief.
Für den eritreischen Flüchtling
und seine Familie
ist das ein entscheidender Schritt
in ihrem Einbürgerungsverfahren.
Okay, Aufgebot
zur Einbürgerungsanhörung.
Mit mir?
- Sì.
Die 14-jährige Hermela
ist ebenfalls eingeladen.
(Langsam) "In Bezug auf
Ihr Einbürgerungsgesuch
laden wir Sie zu einer Anhörung
mit den Mitgliedern der
Einbürgerungskommission Lugano ein."
Mir fehlt ein Knopf.
Er ist abgefallen.
Während sich die Familie
für das orthodoxe Fest
des heiligen Michael bereit macht,
wird Hermela bewusst, was ihr Vater
alles auf sich genommen hat,
um den Schweizer Pass zu bekommen.
Am Anfang hatte ich keine Ahnung,
aber er erklärte mir alles.
Erst glaubte ich,
es sei ganz einfach.
Später verstand ich, dass man
extrem viele Dinge tun muss
und dass es gar nicht
so einfach ist.
Wie sehe ich aus?
- Mh.
Oder doch lieber der weisse?
Nein, das sieht gut aus,
besser als der weisse.- Okay.
Er hat sich extrem engagiert.
Er kam spätabends
nach der Arbeit nach Hause
und fing sofort an, zu lernen.
Am nächsten Tag ging er zur Schule.
Dann kam er heim und lernte wieder.
Er hat sich wirklich Mühe gegeben.
Ciao Mamma.
- Ciao.
(Frau) Carini.
Leteab geht wegen
eines kurzen Spitalaufenthalts
nicht mit in die Kirche,
behält aber ihre Familie
trotzdem im Auge.
Und das bin ich.
Und Papa?
Papa hat diese Schuhe angezogen.
Dawit.
- Ja?
Welche Schuhe hast du angezogen?
Ich habe extra
deine Lacoste-Schuhe geputzt.
Geh sie doch holen,
sie sind im Schrank.- Okay.
Arrivo.
Sie möchte unbedingt, dass wir alle
in Weiss in die Kirche gehen.
Also ziehen wir uns alle weiss an.
In Ordnung, gnädige Frau.
Ciao Mamma.
- Ciao.
Ciao, ci vediamo.
Dawits Kinder kennen nur Lugano.
Das ist weit weg von Eritrea,
wo ihr Vater aufgewachsen ist.
Durch die Gemeindefeste
will Dawit seinen Kindern
ihre Wurzeln näher bringen.
Andreas macht es nichts aus,
stundenlang Auto zu fahren,
um seine Familie zu besuchen.
Sie lebt verstreut
über ganz Deutschland.
(Kind) Ja?
Der Opa.
- Der Opa?
Ja.
Das war mein Enkel.
Die Oma ist auch da.
Und das ist die Flora.
Komm mal her, mein Schatz.
Dieses Wochenende besucht er
seine älteste Tochter Saskia,
um seine zweite Enkelin
kennenzulernen.
Oh, ja.
- Deine neue Enkelin.
* Leise, klagende Töne *
Ja? Den kennst du noch gar nicht,
den Opa, was?
Das ist eine ganz andere Stimme.
Da schaut sie aber.
Ja, aber sie ist nicht ...
- Sie ist eine ganz Friedliche.
Komm mal her.
Begleitet wird Andreas
von seiner Partnerin Birgit,
der Mutter
seiner jüngsten Tochter Lisa.
Gemeinsam haben sie
lange in Freienbach gewohnt.
Vor einem Jahr kehrte Birgit
auf der Suche nach Arbeit
nach Deutschland zurück,
Andreas blieb alleine zurück.
Trotzdem ist er fest entschlossen,
Schweizer Bürger zu werden.
Hallo, Oma Birgit.
- Hallo, Flora.
Ohne seine Familie
hätte Andreas kaum einen Grund,
nach Deutschland zurückzukehren,
denn dabei reissen alte Wunden auf.
Für mich liegt der Unterschied
zwischen der Bundesrepublik
und der Schweiz darin,
dass ich in Westdeutschland
erfahren habe,
dass der Ostdeutsche
weniger wert ist.
Bald 30 Jahre nach der Wende ...
Man ist Ossi.
In der Schweiz hat man
meiner Meinung nach mehr Chancen.
Da zählt man mehr als Mensch.
Mit den Bergen, schön wandern gehen.
Du bist auch gerne beim Opa.
Im Winter
waren wir schon schlitteln.
Nach dem Mauerfall wurde Andreas
den Stempel Ossi nie mehr los
und fühlte sich
von den Westdeutschen
als Verlierer in der Geschichte
abgestempelt.
Andreas ertrug diesen Hohn nicht
und zog in die Schweiz.
Nein!
Kommst du Opa wieder einmal
in der Schweiz besuchen?
Ja.
- Ja?
Aber ... nur am Donnerstag.
Nur am Donnerstag?
Warum nur am Donnerstag?
Komme ich dann zu dir.
Ja, dann können wir
im Wald Pilze sammeln gehen.
Und dann können wir sie essen.
Z.B. da drüben -
das ist eine natürliche Verwerfung.
Sie verläuft ganz unten
auf dem Grund des Meeres.
Wie jedes Jahr plant die Familie
Corona-Cardoso die Ferien
in der touristischen Nebensaison
ihrer Wahlheimat.
Seit 30 Jahren leben
die Hotelangestellten in Pontresina
und arbeiten den ganzen Sommer lang.
Vor der bevorstehenden
Einbürgerungsanhörung
erholt sich die
italienisch-portugiesische Familie
in Anas Heimatstadt Abrantes.
Es ist eine Rückkehr in
das Leben der Kindheit und Jugend.
Damals war das Leben anders.
Alle spielten zusammen
auf der Strasse.
Nein, er wohnt
mit seiner Freundin zusammen.
Jetzt schon?
Ja, jetzt schon.
Sieh an, wie die Zeit rast.
Hier wird immer
mein Zuhause sein ...
... meine Wurzeln,
meine Familie, meine Freunde.
Wir haben ein Haus hier.
Wenn dein Mann und deine Tochter
sich freuen, hierher zu kommen,
ist das immer schön.
Jetzt hast du das Foto ruiniert.
Selbst in den Ferien können die
Unermüdlichen nicht aus ihrer Haut.
Es scheint eine Berufskrankheit
zu sein.
Bei Familie Corona-Cardoso
wird das kleinste Familienessen
zum Festmahl.
Gut, du weisst, dass man sich
bei uns mit drei Küsschen begrüsst.
Das ist die grösste Freude,
wenn ich zurückkomme.
Tante, Cousins, die ganze Familie
siehst du das ganze Jahr nicht.
Man kann sich wie heute spontan
mit der Familie treffen,
sich austauschen, was es Neues gibt
oder wer leider gestorben ist.
Es war heute sehr schön mit
meiner Tante und meinen Cousins.
Wir haben uns lange nicht gesehen.
Hier kann ich endlich einmal
regelmässig essen. Das ist toll.
In der Schweiz schaffe ich es mit
all dem Stress und der Arbeit nicht,
etwas Vernünftiges zu essen.
Als Ana und Paolo
in die Schweiz kamen,
standen sie ganz unten
auf der sozialen Leiter
und mussten für ein besseres Leben
kämpfen.
Stein auf Stein
bauten sie sich hier ein Traumhaus.
Klar kamen wir in die Schweiz,
um Geld zu verdienen.
Aber es ging nicht nur darum,
Geld zu verdienen,
um es nach Hause zu schicken.
Wir führen ein ganz normales Leben,
wie ein Schweizer:
Der wohnt und verdient Geld
in der Schweiz
und hat vielleicht ein Ferienhaus
im Ausland.
Wir haben quasi auch ein Ferienhaus
(Mädchen) Die Dressur
finde ich sehr schön.
Die Pferde haben eine schöne Gang-
art und eine elegante Kopfhaltung.
Die Postur finde ich sehr wichtig.
Heute sind Ana und Paolo stolz,
dass sie ihrer Tochter
eine Kindheit bieten können,
von der sie nie zu träumen wagten.
Mit den Pferden
fühle ich mich einfach frei.
Ich denke an nichts anderes.
Mein Ziel ist, die Schule
in Pontresina zu beenden
und dann eine Lehre zu beginnen.
Dann kann ich nach Portugal kommen
an die Universität von Coimbra.
Wie alle jungen Leute
mit einem C-Ausweis
kann sich auch Chiara
nicht komplett frei bewegen.
Damit sie im Ausland studieren kann,
braucht sie eine Genehmigung
der Schweizer Behörden.
Sonst zählt die komplette Kindheit
in der Schweiz nicht mehr.
Mit dem Pass
wäre diese Gefahr gebannt.
Obwohl Chiara noch jung ist, muss
sie schon nächstes Jahr entscheiden,
was sie in Zukunft machen will.
In der Schweiz haben junge Menschen
viele Perspektiven,
um sich eine bessere Zukunft
und ein sicheres Leben aufzubauen.
Hallo.
Keiner da?
- Ich stille gerade.
Ach, du stillst gerade.
In Stuttgart
jagt ein Besuch den nächsten.
Jetzt darf Andreas' jüngste Tochter
ihre neue Nichte kennenlernen.
Das ist ja so anstrengend.
Jetzt sitzen drei Generationen
auf der Couch.
Lisa ist Flugbegleiterin
und lebt in Berlin.
Ihr Einbürgerungsgesuch
wurde vor fünf Jahren abgelehnt.
Sie kehrte Freienbach und dem Gross-
teil ihrer Jugendzeit den Rücken.
Ich war zwölf, als wir hinzogen.
Ich verbrachte
meine Jahre als Teenager dort,
teilweise auch meine Jahre
als junge Erwachsene.
Für mich war es eine Heimat.
Nur schon, weil
alle meine Freunde Schweizer waren.
Teilweise waren es auch
eingebürgerte Schweizer,
aber das war nie ein Thema.
Es waren einfach meine Freunde,
es waren Schweizer.
Du bist dort zur Schule gegangen
und aufs Gymnasium.
Die Freunde, die Beziehungen,
die man da hatte. Ja.
Sie war auf gutem Weg, Schweizerin zu
werden, hatte alle Hürden gemeistert.
Nur die Anhörung vor der Gemeinde
fehlte.
Die Erinnerung daran
geht ihr immer noch unter die Haut.
Ich fühlte mich
wirklich unter Druck.
Ich wusste einige Dinge nicht,
wie z.B. dieses Naturschutzgebiet.
Frauenwinkel.
- Ja, genau das.
Jetzt weiss man's.
- Ja.
Bei den Sportarten
habe ich Ski und Snowboard gesagt.
Die sind aber international.
- Ja, die sind international.
Jassen, Schwingen und Hornussen.
- (Saskia) Echt jetzt?
Schwingen kannte ich.
Da waren wir öfter auf Festen.
Meine Schweizer Freunde
kannten Schwingen,
weil das in der Schweiz gross ist.
Aber Hornussen oder Steinwerfen
gar nicht.
Als immer weiter und weiter gefragt
und eine Antwort gefordert wurde
und ich keine Antwort geben konnte,
kamen negative Reaktionen.
Nicht als Aussagen,
aber es wurde einfach
mit der Zunge geschnalzt.
Das reicht ja schon.
Man sitzt da alleine?
Ja. Das war furchtbar.
V.a. wenn man 20 Jahre alt ist
und kein Selbstvertrauen hat.
Ich verliess den Saal, das Schloss,
und suchte mir erst mal eine Ecke
und heulte.
Da fühlte ich mich hundsmiserabel,
einfach nicht mehr zugehörig.
Das war der erste Moment,
in dem ich mir dachte:
"Was mache ich jetzt,
wenn meine Heimat nicht mehr
meine Heimat sein möchte?"
"Oder wenn meine Heimat
nicht mehr meine Heimat ist?"
Die Behörden
kreideten Lisa mangelnde Integration
und fehlende Selbstfinanzierung an.
Sie war erst 20
und lebte bei ihren Eltern.
Wie andere in ihrem Alter
hatte sie ihr Studium unterbrochen
und wollte sich neu orientieren.
Somit war sie für die Gemeinde
nicht mehr Studentin.
Das Ablehnungsschreiben
kam nicht alleine -
ihm lag eine Schlussrechnung bei:
1'800 Fr. Verfahrenskosten.
Mir wurde mein C-Ausweis nicht
weggenommen. Ich besass ihn noch.
Mein Leben
spielte sich noch in der Schweiz ab.
Aber das war schon der
zweite Moment, in dem ich dachte:
"Meine Heimat will mich nicht."
Andreas hört die Geschichte
seiner Tochter nicht zum ersten Mal.
Aber jetzt,
da seine eigene Anhörung näher rückt,
bekommen Lisas Worte
eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Hallo.
Ich hoffe natürlich, dass er
im Gespräch auf nette Leute trifft.
Und dass sie
ihm auch entgegenkommen,
wenn es mal bei einer Frage hakt
oder so.
Bis bald. Und wir sehen uns gleich.
- Tschüss, mein Schatz.
Innerlich weiss ich, dass
ich mir keine Sorgen machen muss.
Er schafft das schon.
* Dumpfe, sanfte Klänge *
Frau Benedetto,
können Sie uns sagen,
was eine Initiative ist -
nur auf Bundesebene?
Eine Initia... Einen Moment,
ich muss ein wenig nachdenken.
Ganz ruhig.
Wozu gibt es Initiativen
und wie lanciert man sie?
J'ai ... Ouf.
Herr Benedetto - das Referendum?
Dann können Sie in Ruhe überlegen.
Das Referendum
ist ein politisches Recht,
mit dem die Bürger gegen
einen Beschluss des Parlaments
vorgehen können.
Genau.
Und was müssen die Bürger dafür tun?
Die Bürger müssen Unterschriften
sammeln.
Auf Gemeindeebene
braucht es 8'500 Unterschriften.
Gemeinde. Nein, ich wollte es
auf Bundesebene wissen.
Auf Bundesebene braucht es für
ein Referendum 50'000 in 100 Tagen.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt Frau Benedetto. Vielleicht
läuft es besser mit der Initiative.
Es ist ein politisches Recht.
Die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
schlagen ein Gesetz vor,
mit dem etwas geändert
oder mit dem die Verfassung
teilweise geändert werden soll.
Hervorragend.
Dann also vielen Dank. Wir sind
am Ende dieser Anhörung angelangt.
Das Wort hat nun Frau Kaibach, die
uns das weitere Vorgehen erklärt.
Die Kommission
fällt nun einen Vorentscheid
und übermittel diesen der Gemeinde.
In Lausanne kennen viele
der Kommissionsmitglieder
den beschwerlichen Weg bis zur
Einbürgerung aus eigener Erfahrung.
Ich stamme ursprünglich aus Italien.
Auch wenn niemand
aus meiner Familie hier ist,
weiss ich, dass früher auch Ita-
liener und Spanier kämpfen mussten.
Heute sind sie gut integriert.
Vielleicht wollten sie ursprünglich
in ihre Länder zurückkehren,
aber dann haben sie hier eine Fa-
milie gegründet und wurden heimisch.
Sie blieben und sagten sich:
"Wir müssen uns einbürgern lassen."
Französisch: ausgezeichnet.
Integration ebenfalls.
Sie sind pensioniert.
(Mann) Auch alle Themenbereiche ...
Perfekt. Das ist
nicht immer der Fall. - Oh nein.
Wir hatten Glück.
(Mann) Los, der Nächste.
Comment ça s'est passé?
Es lief sehr gut.
Der Stress ist vorbei.
Jetzt geht's mir besser.
- Mir auch.
Das Resultat bekommen wir in
vier Wochen, haben sie uns gesagt.
Vier bis sechs Wochen.
Bis sechs Wochen? Das ist lange.
Voilà. Alors, on y va?
Aber die Gemeinde ist eher schnell,
wenn man bedenkt, dass es
bestenfalls eineinhalb Jahre dauert,
bis man den Schweizer Pass erhält.
Das Fest des heiligen Michael
in Lugano
ist ein wichtiger Treffpunkt
der eritreischen Gemeinschaft.
In Dawits Leben
spielt Religion eine zentrale Rolle.
Ich bin sehr eng mit
der orthodoxen Kirche verbunden.
Seit neun Jahren
helfe ich bei der Organisation.
Es ist ein grosses Fest
und wird bis morgen dauern.
Meine Frau fehlt mir.
Sie wurde krank
und musste ins Spital.
Zum ersten Mal in neun Jahren
verpasst sie das Fest.
Das ist
v.a. für die Kinder schwierig.
Ich hoffe,
sie kommt bald wieder heim.
Appena iniziato.
* Lachen *
(Hermela)
Für mich ist dieses Fest wichtig,
da die meisten Freundinnen
in Chiasso wohnen.
So können wir uns sehen.
Wenn wir alle zusammen sind,
unter Eritreerinnen,
bin ich mehr ich selber.
Wir kommen alle
aus dem gleichen Land
und haben deshalb
die gleichen Lebensumstände.
Ich fühle mich einfach wohler.
Es kommen sehr viele Eritreer
und Äthiopier aus der ganzen Schweiz
und sogar aus Italien.
Es kommen wirklich
nicht nur Eritreer.
Auch viele Äthiopier
werden heute Abend kommen.
Die Kirche ist, wie Jesus Christus
sagte: "Das Haus meines Vaters".
Eine Messe lang spielt die Entfernung
zwischen der Schweiz und Eritrea
für diese katholische Kirchgemeinde
keine Rolle.
* Hallender feierlicher Gesang *
Wie viele orthodoxe Feste dauert
auch dieses die ganze Nacht hindurch.
Aber nicht alle schaffen es
bis zum Morgengrauen.
(Hermela)
Letztes Jahr war ich ganz vorne.
Das war hart,
denn da waren die Priester.
Ich sagte mir:
"Bloss nicht einschlafen."
Einige Male, als wir uns
von den Bänken erheben mussten,
blieb ich aber sitzen.
Und eine Cousine sagte zu mir:
"Was machst du denn? Steh auf."
* Trillernde Rufe *
Es ist mir wichtig,
an diesen Anlässen dabei zu sein.
Aber man kann auch an Gott glauben,
ohne in die Kirche zu gehen.
* Dumpfes Trommeln,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
* Kirchenglocken *
Bis 1971
hatten nur die Männer das Wahlrecht.
Danach auch die Frauen.
kam die rechtliche Gleichstellung.
Okay.
Ich sage dir das Departement und
du schreibst die Person dazu auf.
Justiz und Polizei.
Karin Keller-Sutter.
- Mhm.
Schweizer/-in zu werden,
ist nicht nur eine Identitätsfrage,
sondern bedeutet auch das Erlangen
der vollen Bürgerrechte.
Ein Viertel der Schweizer Bevölkerung
hat keinen Schweizer Pass.
Davon erfüllt fast 1 Mio.
die Kriterien für eine Einbürgerung.
Ana und Paolo wollen aus
dieser stummen Minderheit ausbrechen.
Los, stell mir Fragen.
Aber übertreibe es nicht.
Wie viele Stimmen
braucht es für ein Referendum?
Wie viele Unterschriften?
- 50'000.
- Bravo.
- Wow.
Wie viele Personen sind in der ...
... in der Bundesversammlung?
Das weiss ich nicht.
246.
- Bravo.
Wow.
2:0.
Wie viele Stimmen
braucht es für das Parlament?
(Chiara) Mir macht es Spass.
So lernen meine Eltern auch Dinge,
die ich in der Schule lerne.
Dann ist es schöner. Ich bin nicht
die Einzige, die das lernen muss.
Aspetta, fammi vedere così.
Chiara half uns sehr.
Sie nahm bestimmte Sachen
von der Schule mit.
Wir schauten uns die Webseiten
von Gemeinde, Kantons und Bund an.
Wir haben uns gut vorbereitet.
Jetzt dieGemeinde Pontresina.
Gemeindepräsident?
- Martin Aebli.
Bei der Familie Corona-Cardoso
steigt die Anspannung.
Morgen fällt bei der Anhörung
vor der Gemeinde die Entscheidung,
ob sie die Einbürgerung
schaffen oder nicht.
Piz Bernina, Piz Palü,
Piz Roseg.
Wie sagt man das auf Rätoromanisch?
Scerscen.
- Scerscen?
(Ana) Gehört Muottas Muragl zu
Pontresina oder Samedan? - Samedan.
Und das Val Roseg?
Samedan.
Das wusste ich.
- Das ist nicht wahr.
Non e vero.
- Okay.
Trotz dem Scheitern seiner Tochter
ist Andreas zuversichtlich.
Er hat alle noch fehlenden Dokumente
eingereicht.
Seine Bewerbung wurde nun
im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht.
"Freienbach, Andreas Luther."
Das bin ich.
"Von Deutschland. Wohnsitz
in der Schweiz seit 13 Jahren."
"Einwände oder Bemerkungen
innert 20 Tagen
kann jedermann zu den
Einbürgerungsgesuchen anbringen."
Da dürfte eigentlich nichts ...
... in der Sache passieren.
Ich habe mit niemandem Ärger
oder Stress.
Ich habe ...
... auch keine polizeilichen
Probleme oder Ähnliches.
Ich parke nicht andauernd
bei jemandem auf dem Parkplatz
oder drangsaliere jemanden.
Daher nehme ich nicht an,
dass sich jemand daran stört,
dass ich mich einbürgern lasse.
Überall in der Schweiz kommt es vor,
dass die Behörden Anschuldigungen
von Bürgern erhalten,
die gegen eine Einbürgerung sind.
Meistens anonym.
Wenn ich an DDR-Zeiten denke -
das Vereinsleben machte Spass.
Als Jugendlicher war ich
beim Bogen- und Luftgewehrschiessen.
Pistolenschiessen gab es nicht.
Sagen wir mal so: Das Schiessen
ist eher schweizerisch.
* Schüsse *
Es ist Entspannung.
Man schaltet ab.
Man fokussiert den Blick
auf das Ziel.
Es bedeutet für mich Entspannung.
Ja, war schon besser als vorher.
100 wäre optimal. Aber davon
bin ich noch meilenweit entfernt.
Da gab es noch anderes.
Mit den Vereinsmitgliedern
geht man mal ein Bierchen trinken.
Man schwatzt,
besucht Veranstaltungen
wie das Morgarten-
oder Rothenturm-Schiessen.
Man sitzt danach noch beieinander.
Das ist etwas anderes, als wenn
man alleine mit dem Schiessgerät
oder mit der Pistole schiesst.
Tschau, Mario. Gleichfalls.
Tschau, Andreas.
- Tschau.
Tschau.
- Tschau. Tschüss.
Wie war's in der Schule?
Bist du aufgeregt? Si?
Si.
Und Papa ist gar nicht da?
Endlich,
drei Monate nach Verfahrensbeginn
ist der grosse Tag
für Familie Corona-Cardoso.
Jetzt ist sie nervös.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen nervös.
- Mich packt es auch.
Die Unsicherheit,
nicht zu wissen, wie es läuft,
wie es ist,
wie es abläuft,
wie es durchgeführt wird,
wer was macht, wer was fragt,
das mag ich nicht.
Für Thomas Walther
ist es ein feierlicher Moment.
Er ist Präsident
der Einbürgerungskommission
und führt die wenigen Anhörungen
in seiner Gemeinde
mit grösster Sorgfalt durch.
In Pontresina gibt es
nur drei bis vier im Jahr.
Die Leute sollen
und können sich vorbereiten.
Es muss eine gewisse Wichtigkeit
und Bedeutung haben.
Eine Staatsbürgerschaft
ist nicht etwas,
das man im Supermarkt kaufen kann.
Man setzt sich damit auseinander,
sie hat langfristige Konsequenzen:
Ich bekenne mich zu diesem Land,
ich bin Schweizerin oder Schweizer.
Das soll
eine gewisse Bedeutung haben.
Dafür darf man ein paar
Schweissperlen auf der Stirn haben.
Das ist ihr komplettes Dossier.
Okay.
Picobello.
Schauen wir kurz die Fragen an.
Es ist auch schwierig, da
in der Kommission Personen sitzen,
die du seit vielen Jahren kennst,
man grüsst sich auf der Strasse.
Aber du weisst nicht,
wie es offiziell abläuft.
Mir ist jetzt schon heiss.
Heiss hier, nicht?
Und wie. Ciao, Ana.
- Geht's gut?
Buongiorno.
- Alles gut?
Ciao.
- Ciao Chiara.
- Buongiorno.
Gut, bitte, kommt herein.
- Danke, grazie.
Jetzt nähert sich dieser Prozess
einem Ende. Quasi alla fine.
(Italienisch) Die Situation
ist nicht ganz angenehm.
Wir sitzen hier
wie eine Art Tribunal.
Aber wir
hegen keine bösen Absichten.
Bereit?
- (Chiara) Si.
Wieso wollt ihr Schweizer werden?
Papa?
Die Schweiz ...
Ich möchte Schweizer werden,
weil ich seit 30 Jahren hier bin.
Ich bin gut integriert.
Ich bin jetzt etwas gestresst.
Ich fühle mich integriert, empfinde
mich schon als Teil der Schweiz.
Das System im Gesamten gefällt mir.
(Schweizerdeutsch) Und du?
Weil Mama und Papa es machen?
Oder machst du es, weil es billiger
ist, wenn es die Eltern bezahlen?
Nein, nein. Ich bin
hier geboren und aufgewachsen.
Auch wenn meine Wurzeln
italienisch und portugiesisch sind,
fühle ich mich auch als Schweizerin,
weil ...
Ich kann es nicht erklären.
Ich fühle mich als Schweizerin,
weil ich seit 14 Jahren hier bin.
Wenn du in Italien
oder Portugal bist
und sagst: "Wir gehen nach
Pontresina", ist das eine Heimkehr?
Oder gehst du nach Hause, wenn
du nach Portugal oder Italien gehst?
Wo ist dein Zuhause?
- Hier in Pontresina.
(Ana)
Das empfinden wir zwei auch so.
Im Mai fahren wir z.B. für drei
Wochen sehr gerne nach Portugal.
Nach drei Wochen ist es Zeit,
zurück nach Hause zu gehen.
Welche Sprache sprecht ihr
zu Hause am Mittagstisch?
Ich spreche mit ihm Rätoromanisch.
Wir verstehen einander.
Er spricht Dialekt
und ich spreche Rätoromanisch.
Es ist eine merkwürdige Mischung.
- Das ist interessant.
Mit mir spricht Chiara
Portugiesisch und Italienisch.
Gut.
Sprechen wir über die Schweiz.
Es geht schliesslich um die Schweiz.
(Hochdeutsch)
Die Schweizer Verfassung
garantiert gewisse ...
... Freiheiten und Rechte.
Italiano?
Paolo darf eine Übersetzung
verlangen,
da Italienisch
zu den Kantonssprachen gehört.
So ohne Weiteres zwischen
drei Landesprachen zu wechseln,
da haben auch viele Schweizer Mühe.
(Italienisch)
Freie Meinungsäusserung.
(Italienisch) Also, freie Meinungs-
äusserung, Religionsfreiheit.
Wahlfreiheit.
Und wer ist mehr wert,
die Frau oder der Mann?
(Ana) Geschlechtergleichheit.
- Molto importane.
Seit ...
- 1981.
(Thomas) Nein.
- 1971.
Punto.
(Hochdeutsch)
Wir haben ja Bundesräte.
Wie viele?
- (Ana) Sette.
Kennt ihr von einigen den Namen?
Ignazio Cassis.
- Gut.
Sommaruga.
Ueli Maurer.
- Berset, Ueli Maurer.
Amherd.
Genau.
Wie viele Kantone hat die Schweiz?
(Alle) 26.
(Frau) Vi siete aspettati
questa domanda.- Questa si.
Das haben wir als erstes wiederholt:
"Papa, es sind 26.".
Ganz richtig.
(Italienisch) Was wird am 1. März
im Engadin gefeiert?
(Alle) Chalandamarz.
Am 1. August?
- (Alle) Festa federale.
Im September?
Beginn der Jagdsaison.
(Frau) 1'000 Punkte.
- Ja, das gibt 1'000 Punkte.
(Rätoromanisch)
Gehen wir zu den Gewässern.
Wie heisst der Fluss,
der in Pontresina entspringt?
(Chiara) Inn.
Nein, hier fliessen zwei zusammen.
Etwas mit F. Der ...
(Ana) Flaz.
Das ist der Flaz.
Und wo mündet er?
Wo fliesst er hin?
- Inn.
Und der Inn fliesst wohin?
- Rhein?
Nein.
Der Rhein fliesst durch Chur.
Der andere fliesst woanders durch.
Wo?
Da hatte ich Angst,
dass ich den Pass
wegen diesem blöden Blackout
nicht bekomme.
Sie weinte, das muss ich sagen.
Sie sagte: "Mama, vielleicht
habe ich alles kaputt gemacht."
"Vielleicht
bekommen wir den Pass nicht,
weil es mir
in diesem Moment nicht gut lief."
Das Schwarze Meer?
Gibt es das?
Gut. Haben wir weitere Fragen?
Io no.
- No.
Die Anhörung geht zu Ende.
Nach der intensiven Vorbereitung
fast ein bisschen enttäuschend.
(Italienisch) Wir wissen sogar, wer
der Präsident des Grossen Rates ist:
Alessandro Della Vedova.
(Chiara)
Und Vizepräsident ist Wieland.
2017 war es Martin Aebli.
(Beide) 2016, Michael Pfäffli.
(Alle) 2001, Rodolfo Plozza.
Wir kennen auch die vier Gipfel.
- Si, è vero.
Dann noch die vier Gipfel.
Piz Bernina, Piz Palü,
Piz Roseg e Piz Scerscen.
Sehr gut. Alle bestiegen?
Wir gehen oft in die Berge.
Zum Wandern. Habt ihr
diese Gipfel auch bestiegen?
Die muss man gemacht haben.
Familie Corona
kennen wir schon lange.
Wenn wir sie nicht gekannt hätten,
wäre das Gespräch anders gewesen.
Adesso, a presto.
- Va bene.
Grazie.
- Grazie a voi.
Uns interessiert v.a., wieso jemand
Schweizer/-in werden will.
Da bekamen wir schon Antworten wie:
"Mit dem roten Pass
kann man einfacher reisen."
Das kann nicht sein.
Dann brachen wir das Gespräch direkt
ab und wünschten einen schönen Tag.
Das sind für uns keine Gründe,
Schweizer/-in zu werden.
(Mann) Nun der dritte Kandidat,
Dawit Mengstab, geboren 1974.
Dawit Mengstab ist am 24. Februar
1974 in Asmara, Eritrea geboren.
Er hat ein Gesuch für sich
und seine drei Kinder eingereicht.
Dawits und Hermelas grosser Tag.
Gleich müssen sie der
Luganer Kommission entgegentreten,
die beeindruckende 13 Mitglieder hat.
Diese prüfen
unter dem Vorsitz von Enea Petrini
das Dossier ein letztes Mal
bis ins kleinste Detail.
Zu seiner Lebensgeschichte:
Nach der Matura hat er den obliga-
torischen Militärdienst geleistet -
zehn Jahre lang.
Wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe.
Zehn Jahre.
Darauf müssen wir
vielleicht genauer eingehen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist schon wahr.
Im November 2006 entscheidet
er sich, sein Leben zu ändern,
kommt hier als Asylsuchender an
und bekommt einen L-Ausweis.
Er besuchte Italienischkurse,
um das Sprachniveau B1 zu erreichen.
Auch den Gesellschaftstest hat er
bestanden. Er ist verheiratet.
Für seine Frau
liegt kein Gesuch vor,
weil sie
noch nicht lange genug hier lebt.
Es gibt keine laufenden Fahndungen,
Verfahren oder Klagen gegen ihn.
Begründung für das Gesuch:
"Meine Familie und ich
fühlen uns vollständig
in die wirtschaftlichen,
sozialen, kommunalen,
kantonalen und nationalen Strukturen
integriert."
Danke, dann können sie hereinkommen.
Buona sera, Signor Mengstab. Prego.
Ich war die Jüngste.
Sonst waren nur Erwachsene da.
Sie befragten auch mich.
Ich dachte:
"Evtl. fragen sie Dinge,
dich ich nicht weiss."
Da wurde ich etwas nervös.
Natürlich sind die Bewerber ge-
stresst, wenn sie den Raum betreten.
Sie warten draussen und wissen
nicht, was drinnen vor sich geht.
Wir wussten,
dass da 13 Leute sein würden,
aber wir wussten nicht,
was sie uns fragen.
In Pontresina warten Corona-Cardosas
auf das Ergebnis ihrer Anhörung.
Chiara beginnt ein Praktikum
im Hotel, wo ihr Vater arbeitet.
Fühlen Sie sich hier in der Gemeinde
zu Hause und integriert?
Ja.
In Freienbach kämpft Andreas
vor der Einwanderungsbehörde damit,
nicht komplett
den Faden zu verlieren.
Wahlfreiheit und ...
Questo palazzo, cosa viene fatto
all' interno di queste mura?
Vor der imposanten Kommission
von Lugano
riskiert Dawit seine Einbürgerung -
und diejenige seiner Familie.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020